what i want to do in this video is
really digest the idea that if we have
some fraction as long as we multiply the
numerator and the denominator of the
fraction by the same number that we're
going to have an equivalent fraction so
let's think about that let's say we
multiply the denominator here by two
so let's say we multiply the denominator
here by two i'm claiming that as long as
we multiply the numerator by two that
we're going to get an equivalent
fraction
so here the denominator was 6 so here
our denominator will be 12. if our
numerator here is 4 well we've got to
multiply by 2 again
multiply our numerator by 2 to get 8. so
i'm claiming that 8 12 is the same
fraction as 4 6 and to visualize that to
visualize that let me redraw let me
redraw this whole
but instead of having
6 equal sections we now have 12 equal
sections so each of the six we can
divide we can turn into two that's
essentially what multiplying by two does
we now have twice as many equal sections
now that we have twice as many equal
sections literally one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve how many of them are actually
shaded in yellow well it's one two three
four five six seven eight eight twelve
so there's no magic here if each of if
if we have twice as many sections we're
going to have to shade in twice as many
of them in order to have the same
fraction of the whole
and it goes the other way too this isn't
just true with multiplication it's also
true that if we divide the numerator and
the denominator by the same quantity
that we are going to have an equivalent
fraction
so that's another way of saying well
what happens if i were to divide by 2.
so if i were to divide by 2
so let me divide by 2
i'm going to have half half the number
of equal of sections or i will only have
equal sections and i'm claiming if i do
the same thing in the numerator that
this is going to represent the same
same fraction so 4 divided by two is two
so i'm claiming that two thirds
is the same fraction as four sixths as
the same fraction as eight twelves well
let's visualize that
so here this is six equal sections but
now we're going to have only three equal
sections so we can merge we can merge
some of these equal sections so we can
merge
these two right over here and we can
merge these two right over here and then
we can merge and then we can merge these
two
right over here
so our hole is where it's still the same
hole but now we've only we only have
three equal sections and two of them are
actually shaded in so these are all
equivalent fractions so the big takeaway
here is start with a fraction if you
multiply the same if you multiply the
numerator and the denominator by the
same quantity you're going to have an
equivalent fraction if you divide the
numerator and the denominator by the
same quantity you are also going to have
an equivalent fraction
so with that in our brains let's tackle
a little bit of an equivalent fractions
problem
let's think about if someone says okay i
have
over
and i want to write that as sum
as some value let's call that value t
let's call that t
over
100 what would t be
well we can see in the denominator to go
from 25 to 100 you had to multiply by 4.
so if you want an equivalent fraction
you have to multiply the numerator by 4
as well
so t will need to be equal to 20. so t
is equal to 20. 5 over 20 fifths is the
same thing
is the same thing as
20 as 20
over 100 but what if someone says well 5
over 25 is equivalent is equivalent to
blank let's say question mark over 5.
well now what would you do actually
let's do it the other way is equal to
is equal to 1 over
question mark
well you could say look to go get our
numerator from 5 to 1
we have to divide by 5.
we have to divide by 5 to go from 5 to 1
and so similarly we have to divide the
denominator by 5. so if you divide the
denominator by 5 25 divided by 5 is
going to get you
is going to get you five
going to get you five so these are all
equivalent fractions one-fifth is
equivalent to five twenty-fifths which
is equal to twenty-one hundredths